[Musique]
pour l'équipe de bonnes adresses du
passé comme pour vous le mois d'août ce
sont les vacances vous nous en
voudraient donc pas de modifier en cette
occasion notre présentation habituelle
est de vous emmener flâner dans ce haut
lieu du tourisme international qui
s'appelle la tour eiffel depuis 1889
plus de 30 millions de citoyens du monde
ont escaladé la tour quelques rares
sportifs l'ont fait à pied les autres
comme vous et moi on préférait prendre
l'ascenseur
[Musique]
elle est
[Applaudissements]
il est donc fondé devant une telle
affluence
à se demander quels sont les réflexes
conditionnés que la tour provoque chez
l'homme moderne
ils sont trois ordres celui qui voit la
tour éprouve une médiatement le besoin
d'y monter arrivée au sommet il passera
la plupart de son temps à se fabriquer
des souvenirs à l'aide de réactions
chimiques qui font intervenir la
cellulose la gélatine le nitrate
d'argent et le soleil enfin il procurera
un surcroît de travail aux employés des
postes du monde entier par l'expédition
a considéré d'une quantité
invraisemblable de cartes postales en
noir et en couleurs qui décriront le
sommet atteint sans toutefois préciser
la phase ii l'escaladent mais du sommet
quel point de vue un pari lilliputiens
ou l'automobile et fourmies la scène
joli ruban bouclée et le palais de
chaillot jouets d'enfants rené clair lui
même fut sensible à tout ce charme à
l'époque où chaillot second fait encore
entre cadets rococo d'où il pouvait
filmer le drapeau de la tour qui
n'avaient pas encore cédé sa place aux
antennes de la télévision
[Musique]
quant à louis blériot il était lui en
pleine science-fiction
[Musique]
touristes jeu des temps de remercier
monsieur est fait sans lui vous n'auriez
que notre dame le sacré coeur la sainte
chapelle et tombeau de l'empereur
grâce à lui paris est à vos pieds et
vous pouvez vous offrir le luxe d'un
vertige à prix fixe d'excellente qualité
voilà un fait acquis reconnu et ventée
du camembert au papier peint en passant
par le charme des parisiennes et les
limonades britanniques ont la dansé et
chanté sur tous les airs connus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il était donc normal que notre émission
revienne à son tour rendre son hommage
aux grands ingénieurs
[Musique]
et
oh
mais la bonne adresse d'aujourd'hui ne
sera pas là tous non pour retrouver
monsieur eiffel nous traverserons la
scène et là bas derrière la maison de la
radio qui s'achève enfui au coeur même
d'auteuil
nous découvrirons le laboratoire
d'aérodynamique dont on a fêté cette
année le cinquantenaire et qui fut
l'oeuvre du grand savant à la fin de sa
vie
[Musique]
c'est là que nous attend son actuel
directeur monsieur chat bona
demain
délaissé en partie aux briques de terre
de temps en temps des conneries
jamais
qu'est ce que vous faisiez qu'est-ce
qu'on n'y ait plus de joueurs et en
suivant la direction défilent à deir
montre qu'elle est l'écoulement autour
de la maquette c'est l'instrument le
plus simple du laboratoire est peut-être
le plus précieux on ne fait pas ça parce
que ça vaut pas cher et tout le reste
vous vous pliez 6 6 1 go d'argent on
voit beaucoup de choses avec une canne à
pêche à en quoi consiste exactement
le laboratoire est bien le regard des
téléspectateurs si vous l'entendez le
dos ils ont fait contre le laboratoire
comporte une soufflerie de deux mètres
de diamètre comportant trois organes
principaux le collector c'est cette
sorte d'entonnoir par laquelle l'air
entre avant de pénétrer dans la chambre
d'expérience nous sommes où il atteint
sa vitesse maximum il passe ensuite dans
le diffuseur avant d'arriver au
ventilateur actionné par an moteur de 50
chevaux moteur électrique est alors le
courant d'air quel retour par le haut la
pression réduite
alors ici c'est la chambre d'expérience
dans lesquels on trouve dans laquelle on
installe toutes sortes d'appareils de
mesure destinés aux différents essais
que nous effectuerons l'honneur en ce
qui concerne la balance pour essayer de
bâtir automobile qu'il est ici elle
comporte dans l'épaisseur du plancher
tout un dispositif dont vos gosses ils
dont voici le détail les appareils de
mesure étant reliée au dispositif
extenseurs métriques qui sont dans la
balance elle-même par ses fils tricolore
qui aboutisse alors aux galbes à nos
maîtres de précision et aux appareils de
réglages qui permettent d'effectuer le
mesure des mesures le déplacement du
spot des galvanomètre indique la valeur
des efforts dans le même temps on
effectue la valeur la mesure de la
vitesse au moyen d'un manomètre incliné
qui est placée là bord et un putsch
n'est averti l'expérimentateur que la
lecture est faite ici et en même temps
la banque et ça permet de dire mme de
déterminer les meilleures formes
aérodynamiques des
véhicule ça permet d'étudier non
seulement les meilleures formes mais
aussi la tenue de route la stabilité des
véhicules par conséquent c'est très
important d'aider les 24 heures du mans
parisien 24 heures du mans la voiture
qui a gagné l indice de performance
c'est une voiture deutsch dans art qui a
été étudiée ici il n'y a pas tellement
longtemps
la première voiture à turbine française
de chez renault l'étoile filante avait
aussi été étudiée ici elle a fait 320
kilomètres à l'heure sur le lac salé et
en dehors des voitures au tour de ville
qu'est-ce que vous étudiez bien nous
étudions certainement beaucoup d'avions
puisque le laboratoire a été créée au
début oui mais les idées surtout les
richesses des avions n'ont aucun rapport
avec une soufflerie de 100 kilomètres à
l'heure d'accord mais un avion qui vole
à trois milles à l'heure il commence par
rouler à 50 à 100 il est collé 150 ou
200 et le problème de l'atterrissage est
aussi très délicats
c'est le retour au sol et c'est à ce
moment là en général que les avions sont
déficients donc nous pouvons travailler
dans les petites vitesses maintenant les
avions d'affaires les avions de tourisme
tout ça en des vitesses compatible avec
la soufflerie à laurent d'heure de la
partie aviation nous étudions aussi des
appareils à décollage vertical dont on
parle de plus en plus qui sont les
appareils de l'avenir puisqu'ils
permettront aux parisiens de s'en aller
de chez eux sans avoir à rencontrer les
agents les feux rouges et ses 30 ans
heureux nous en sommes très proches
et alors nous étudions aussi pour
l'électronique des centaines de radars
dont on doit déterminer les coefficients
de résistance etc des bâtiments des
usines toutes sortes de choses
d'ailleurs vous allez voir en bas dans
la salle des maquettes un certain nombre
de choses qui vous est intéressant là je
vais vous suivent et basse et ce alors
si vous voulez nous allons continuer
laissez vous voulez vous remettra en
route s'il vous plaît
restons donc fumée au vent de la
soufflerie
cette maquette du sinn les études du
laboratoire permettront d'éviter aux
maisons qu'il avoisine d'être souillé
par les poussières qui s'en échappe
il en sera de même pour ce modèle de
capte suis dont on s'assure ici de
l'efficacité l'installation de ces
engins sur les cheminées des grands
centres urbains sera prochainement
obligatoire leur bon fonctionnement nous
évitera la noirceur de nos villes on
recherche ici en vraie grandeur
les modèles qui auront le meilleur
rendement
eh bien nous pénétrons à nouveau dans le
monde de lilliput et cette maquette
appelle un souvenir c'est un pavillon
n'est ce pas c'est en effet le liant de
la france à bruxelles qui a été étudiée
entièrement soufflerie car il s'agissait
de quelque chose de nouveau
en effet vous avez entendu dire
certainement que dans l'esprit de
l'homme qui est conçu cet ensemble la
flèche devait équilibrer sur une sphère
l'ensemble du bâtiment qui est l'autre
côté il est évident que c'est une vue de
l'esprit car le poids de la toiture et
de ce bâtiment est nettement supérieur à
l'autre et enfin point de vue volume on
peut dire que c'est c'est exact une
particularité c'est la construction des
toitures qui a été réalisé au moyen de
câbles prétendu qui repose sur quatre
poutres de rive
étant donné que la toiture ainsi réalisé
pèse environ 8 kg au mètre carré alors
que les triture classique réalisé en
béton en pèse 200 l'influencent du vent
avait donc une importance considérable
c'est pourquoi cette maquette a fait
l'objet d'études tout à fait
particulière voici alors là votre monde
c'est à dire le monde pour lequel le
laboratoire a été créé le monde
d'aviation sais mais j'ai pas
l'impression d'avoir vu cette maquette
d'avion volée c'est en effet un premier
jet d'un avion des fermes mené jupiter
qui a été étudiée ici
cet appareil était très jolie au point
de vue forme mais il ne répondait pas
aux normes de réalisation sont imposés
maintenant aux avions d'autre part étant
donné qu'ils étaient très courts les
problèmes de centrage été relativement
délicat ça donc permis de faire une
évolution de la machine que voici sous
sa forme définitive
voyez que l'avion qui était madame
auteur s'est transformé en bimoteur une
et distractives
ce propulsive l'empennage a été reculée
la cabine a été agrandie en somme ça a
donné un appareil beaucoup plus
séduisant ayant des qualités de vol
remarquable et je vois à côté c'est une
hélice non c'est l'esprit de lieux
montant vers le ciel
autrement dit d'une oeuvre une oeuvre
d'artiste qui a voulu exprimer ceci sous
forme d'une flamme qui sera érigé ou qui
est même érigé à côté maintenant de la
cathédrale de fort-lamy laquelle
dimension ça des 25 mètres de hauteur en
raison de sa forme même il est évident
qu'il était très difficile de déterminer
la structure pour que ça résiste au vent
qui règne dans cette contrée et c'est le
laboratoire qui a été chargée de mesurer
les composantes parallèle
perpendiculaire au vent les moments de
renversement puisque a permis de
construire une armature proportionnelle
aux efforts exactement qui se
répartissent à l'intérieur qui m'arrive
c'est incalculable laboratoire seul peut
donner des chiffres permettant une telle
réalisation
et ça variait selon la direction des
vents aussi je préviens voilà encore un
ensemble architectural que nous
connaissons tous bien
il s'agit du cnid bien su en effet c'est
le palais des expositions de la défense
pour la première fois on ait réalisé des
voûtes sans aucun tir en extérieur de
220 m de portée
étant donné que ce bâtiment a été
construit sur un monticule qui domine
neuilly higuain par conséquent des vents
c'est important
il a fallu étudier la maquette dans les
phases de construction qui ont été
réalisés en particulier vous savez qu'on
a fait des sécheurs fois d'âge tubulaire
et qu'on a coffré écoulée la voûte avant
de faire les parois à ce moment là si le
vent s'engouffre sur la voûte
vous avez une aile avec une courbure
considérable avec un allongement très
faible par conséquent des normes et
tourbillons marginaux provoquant des
pressions internes et des dépressions
nous avons ensuite alors le bâtiment
terminé c'est-à-dire avec ses façades
tel qu'il est là déterminés les efforts
du auvent puis nous avons étudié la
ventilation de l'ensemble du bâtiment
en somme vous avez beaucoup de
chose construite dans la nature qui ont
été étudiées au laboratoire de mais
celle ci est qu'est ce que c'est ceci
c'est un projet d'avion c'est un
inventeur qui avait dans l'idée de faire
voler un tuyau de poêle à l'origine et
ma foi ouvriers action tuyaux évolué
puisque maintenant vous avez des
quantités d'éléments cylindres au
comique avec une hélice et tissier qui
doit augmenter la circulation de l'air
ceux ci monté sur une voilure de petites
allongement une voilure plate par
conséquent n'ayant pas de très grande
qualité de portance sage 3ème que ça n'a
jamais volé sa n'ai jamais volé aussi un
avion torpilleur qui date du début de la
guerre de 39 40 avions torpilleurs qui
est étudié en soufflerie en dessous vous
avez la maquette d'un des quadrimoteur
latécoère célèbre par toute une série
d'appareils remarquables parmi lesquels
on peut citer la croix du sud sur
laquelle mermoz ce grand pilote a
disparu malheureusement c'est vers les
années 27-28 vous avez dû travailler sur
ces mannequins tour de 1930
ici vous avez une maquette de bâtiments
de cadarache pour l'énergie atomique
sont des études de fumée alors études
d'alimentation en air frais pour les
gens qui travaillent à l'intérieur du
bâtiment et évacuation des fumées
produites mais ça ce n'est pas un avion
c'est une horreur
c'est un élément d'avion c'est un
empennage qui est précédé d'un corps
reconstituant l'écoulement qui
existerait si le fuselage entier étaient
là mais ce fut via je ne pourrions pas
le mettre dans la soufflerie vu ses
dimensions
alors on a un écoulement du corps et
c'est parce que la partie qui vous
intéressent commencé c'est uniquement
ici ça alors nous déterminons sur ces
gouverne les efforts pour les manoeuvrer
l'action elle-même des gouvernes au
moyen de dispositifs de mesure
appropriée par conséquent on peut
déterminer en particulier les efforts
que le pilote aura à fournir pour
manoeuvrer son avion ici nous sommes
dans tout un monde
à échelle réduite toujours l'énergie
atomique ce sont des bâtiments de saclay
sur lesquels nous avons étudié
l'évacuation des fumées
ici la centrale nucléaire de chinon
construite dans une sphère de 55 mètres
de diamètre avec des orifices
d'écoulement terre ici la centrale
thermique qui est construite à une
certaine distance de la première
problème d'évacuation des fumées bien
entendu de façon à assurer le confort
aux gens qui habitent cette centrale là
vous reconnaissez certainement le
château d'eau si caractéristique de
saclay avec la très belle allée d'arbres
qu'il précède des bâtiments clair ce
sont les bâtiments qui existait ici ce
sont des bâtiments en projets sur
lesquels on nous a demandé de faire
l'étude de l'entrée d'air et évacuation
des fumées
eh bien je vois qu'en dépit de la date
de sa fondation le laboratoire eiffel
n'est pas resté en retard et qui
travaille pour le présent et pour le
futur et il me plaît de faire cette
remarque au moment où nous arrivons
devant ce ventilateur est ce que par
hasard ils dateraient de l'époque de
monsieur eiffel
hélas oui l'aide de 1912 il a toujours
un rendement lamentable de 50% et vous
n'avez pas trouvé un mécène
il ya peu une destination pour changer
le moteur ya plus de mécènes de nos
jours et je crois que le laboratoire
finira avec ce ventilateur que je subis
depuis 23 ans
on ne parlons pas de la fin du
laboratoire vous venez de fêter son
cinquantenaire il est en pleine
expansion quand même certainement et
nous allons profiter du fait que nous
sommes devant ce ventilateur qui a fait
installer lui-même monsieur eiffel si
vous voulez bien pour que je vous
demande ce que monsieur effet là
exactement à mener au laboratoire en
quoi était son action eh bien monsieur
eiffel a construit un premier
laboratoire au champ de mars avec un
moteur de 50 chevaux il obtenait une
veine d'air de 18 mètres de vitesse par
seconde dans un diamètre d'un mètre
cinquante
lorsqu'il a conçu l'ensemble dont vous
avez vu le schéma tout à l'heure c'est à
dire la soufflerie que nous venons de
voir
il a obtenu avec la même puissance de 50
chevaux une vitesse de 30 mètres seconde
dans un diamètre de 2 m ceci grâce à la
récupération d'énergie produite dans le
diffuseur mais ces recherches
aérodynamiques
est ce qu'ils les avaient commencé
prélablement il avait avant de faire les
essais en soufflerie utiliser l'appareil
de chute qui est dans lé hall de la
soufflerie d'ailleurs auprès de cet
appareil de chute vous voyez monsieur le
graët fait le petit fils de monsieur
eiffel
si vous permettez je vais aller lui
poser quelques questions à propos de son
grand père je vous en prie monsieur
legrand eiffel nous est là devant
l'appareil qui a conçu votre grand-père
pour étudier la résistance de l'air en
se servant de la tour eiffel est ce que
vous pourriez nous expliquer son
fonctionnement est bien volontiers cet
appareil se compose d'un cadre ou sont
attachés les appareils de mesure
du christ y porte une plaque ce tube se
déplacent le long de cet axe de me
suivant l'importance de l'effort qui est
appliquée à la plaque
lorsque l'on fait tomber l'ensemble de
ce dispositif le long d'un comme la
plaque se compriment et vient
enregistrer les efforts du vent sur les
appareils et qui se trouve à l'intérieur
de ce qu'offre la l'appareil était monté
au deuxième étage de la tour eiffel et
le fils faisait donc environ 120 m
les résultats ont été très satisfaisants
mais par lorsqu'il y avait du monde côté
évidemment les expériences ne donnait
pas des résultats concordants
c'est donc à ce moment là que votre
grand père a pensé aux souffleries c'est
exactement à ce moment là au lieu de
déplacer la pac dans le vent il a
déplacé le vent autour de la peur et ses
effets ont été concluants au point de
vue des coefficients et les essais se
sont révélés et pareil ne soit dans le
cas de la plaque se déplaçant dans le
vent c'est à dire le système que vous
voyez ici soit lorsqu'on dépasser 2
vantaux la pac c'est à dire les essais
en soufflerie
ce sont la base de ces erding ce sont
les débuts de l'aérodynamisme est une
application pratique à l'époque ce que
les dirigeants qui comme on le voit sur
ce dessin avait un bec pointu c'est à
dire se diriger la pointe en avant
gustave eiffel a prouvé qu'il tenait se
diriger le bourreau en avant et être
pointu à l'extrémité arrière je vous
demandais si vous le voulez bien de nous
raconter la vie et l'oeuvre de votre
grand-père mes plaisirs ghost avait fait
l' ennemi à dijon le 15 décembre 1832
dans la maison de là
du canal où est aujourd'hui à poser une
plaque commémorative et pelles disait de
mon père je tiens le bout de l'aventuré
et de ma mère l'amour du travail et des
responsabilités dans cette famille lisez
13 unis le jeune eiffel est un enfant
sans histoire billes heureuse et un de
ses plus beaux souvenirs et est
certainement celui qui nous évoquait
souvent sans voyage à paris à l'âge de
12 ans en diligence
elle était convenu qu'il prendrait la
succession de son oncle molherat à la
tête de son usine qui fabriquait des
spécialités bourguignonnes réputé
eaux-de-vie vinaigre mais l'oncle
molherat avait un caractère aussi acide
de son vinaigre
il se brouille avec sa famille à petite
cause grands effets aigus ce père vettel
va se lancer dans les constructions
mettait à 26 ans un industriel monsieur
ne veut qu'ils avaient apprécié et lui
confie la construction du grand pont de
chemin de fer de bordeaux il s'en tire
remarquablement et cette grande oeuvre
vote aux jeunes et fait l'admiration des
ingénieurs de l'administration et des
chemins de fer
la construction de ce pont avait révélé
non seulement l'ingénieur mais aussi
l'homme
son souci de la sécurité ces ouvriers le
dévouement dont il fit preuve en se
jetant tout habillé dans la garonne pour
sauver l'un d'entre eux qui se noyait
avait provoqué la confiance et
l'admiration de ses ouvriers qui lui
offrir une médaille commémorative à la
fin d'être à l'année 2008 166 marquent
la vie des faits il va travailler pour
son propre compte et créer un bureau
d'études puis ses propres ateliers à
levallois-perret en 1869 il aborde les
grands ouvrages avec le viaduc de
nauviale puis avec le verdict de la
sioule long de 162 m et haut de 51m il
va mettre en oeuvre des idées nouvelles
il commence à s'affranchir de la faune
matériaux lourds cassant les piles de la
sioule présente deux caractéristiques
importantes d'abord les angles des piles
sont encore constitué par des colonnes
de fond mais avec des entretoises de
faire pour l'y la fonte au bout c'est en
faire sur lesquels seront rivés les
entretoises il imagine de fixer les
goussets pendant la coulée de la fonte
ensuite deuxième caractéristique la
forme même des piles les arts est
incurvé données lan base plus large et
une plus grande stabilité
nous présentons la forme de la tour
eiffel je crois que c'est à cette époque
que le gouvernement portugais le chargea
de la construction du pont sur le doro
[Musique]
le problème était difficile la voie du
chemin de fer de lisbonne à porto devait
franchir le douro à une hauteur de 61
mètres au dessus du niveau du sol dont
la très grande profondeur à cet endroit
rendait impossible la construction de
tout appui intermédiaire la largeur du
fleuve 160 mètres devait donc être
franchie par une seule ab heppell
propose à sa solution du pont en arc qui
pour son audace sa sécurité et son
élégance enleva l'approbation du jeu la
solution dfl comportait deux innovations
qui depuis fierté coll d'abord la
réalisation de lave ou de support par
deux arcs en forme de croissant ensuite
l'obliquité d2 à l'un part à portal o de
manière à donner une base très stable
pour résister aux efforts du vent cette
technique se retrouvent dans les voûtes
support du premier étage de la tour
eiffel
la réussite du pont du douro fut complet
aussi quand il s'agit d'édifier le
fameux viaduc de garabit c'est afl que
l'on s'adresse à ce viaduc de garabit
avait une longueur totale de 105 164 m
dont 448 pour la partie métallique
il repose sur cinq piles dont la plus
haute à 90 mer ses dimensions
considérables font de cet ouvrage le
plus important qui avait été jusqu alors
qu'on se fait en france le poids de
métal clientes des 3250 cape town et son
prix on n'y comprenant les maçonneries
étaient des 3 millions cent trente sept
mille francs c'est à dire un franc le
kilo
oui fl avait fait la preuve de la valeur
de ses solutions révolutionnaires la
même que quelques années plus tôt lorsqu
il construisit la charpente de l'immense
statue de la liberté que bartholdi
sculptait pour le port de new york
on oublie souvent la taille de cette
statue rien que l'index mesure de mettre
allait-il appliquer tous ces
enseignements la construction de la tour
et bien effet les prêts à construire la
tour qui sera une synthèse de ces
solutions
après réflexion sachant d'après ces
travaux antérieurs qu'il pouvait
réaliser ce projet heppell pouvait avec
une précision suffisante en estimer le
prix la tour comme le viaduc de garabit
coûtera 1 point kg jetons un coup d'oeil
sur le développement technique en 1884
les engins de levage et le matériel de
chantier sont rudimentaires ou
inexistants tout doit se faire à la main
c'est dans ces conditions que gustave
eiffel vont entreprendre ce qui paraît
un défi à ses contemporains et pourtant
du 28 janvier 1887 au 31 mars 1889 7000
tonnes de fer allait être mise en oeuvre
ajustez montée et river toutes les
pièces arrivait à pied d'oeuvre perret
est achevée il suffisait de les hisser à
l'endroit où elle devait prendre place
chef-d'oeuvre de préfabrication avant
l'invention de ce mot aucun trou de
rivets ne fut percé sur le champ de mars
tout avait été fait en atelier je
voudrais également souligné
l'obstination avec laquelle il exige l
observation des règles de sécurité dans
le travail au cours de la construction
de la tour construction sans précédent
et particulièrement dangereuse
il impose à des consignes si prudent et
si sévère que la réalisation ne t'a pas
du seul binaire avec la tour gustave
eiffel aurait pu terminer sa carrière
pas du tout après sa vie d'ingénieurs
cet homme dont l'esprit mais ne met pas
la vieillesse entrepris sa seconde sa
carrière celle du savon en même temps il
va démontrer que la tour de 300 mètres
et pas seulement aux demandes presti le
symbole de la france reconnaissante
après ce désastre de 70 mais aussi un
merveilleux support pour les techniques
nouvelles
déjà quand il avait présenté un projet
il avait eu soin des sites et quelques
applications scientifiques possibles
observatoire météorologique observatoire
astronomique laboratoire des physiques
permettant la vérification des lois de
la pesanteur la démonstration de la
rotation de la terre l'étude de la
déviation d'un accord qui tombe l'
observatoire stratégique poste de
communication par télégraphie optique
mêmes phare pour l'éclairage et licques
ceux qui se réalisera quelques soixante
ans plus tard ils pressent le
développement de l'aviation d'hui qui
avait passé sa vie à lutter contre le
vent richard s est ouvrable
il sait que la métérologie
aérodynamiques sont deux sciences
indispensable pour la première la tour
est un merveilleux poste observations
quant à la seconde
la tour sera son premier laboratoire il
devine davantage que cette antenne
géante constitue l'atout il offre au
capitaine fériés et pointent tous les
frais à sa charge en 1991 franchissait
400 km puis en 1906 3000 km en 21
le célèbre poste radio tour eiffel et
mettez régulièrement la tour était donc
toujours à l'avant-garde du progrès et
cela n'est pas un des moindres miracle
des réalisations de gustave eiffel
d'être toujours rester dans cette
avant-garde là
ce laboratoire d'aérodynamique qui fut
notre bonne adresse d'aujourd'hui et
encore en dépit de la vétusté de son
moteur à la pointe de la recherche
c'est en effet ici que l'on étudie le
comportement du futur pont sur la main
la maquette du pont munis de grillage
anti bouras résiste au vent de la
vieille soufflerie de monsieur fm et
demain les automobilistes qui rompt
viendront d'angleterre ne devront un peu
aux constructeurs de la tour où ils
pourront eux aussi rendre hommage aux
grands ingénieurs
[Musique]